alright guys this is crazy how's the 24
core faster than the 32 core this video
is brought to you by squarespace the
best way to make an amazing website
today we will find out once and for all
is the 32 core m1 max a rip off and is
the 24 chord the one you want to get we
finally got our hands on a 24 core
thanks to xi wu a follower on twitter so
thank you for making this possible and
we not only have two 16 inch macbook
pros right in front of us i also have a
32 core m1 max 14 inch model so we will
also get to see
does the 24 core 16 inch model be out or
compete with the 32 quart 14 inch and
these things cost the same exact price
with those differences and not only are
we going to show you guys the
performance differences but something
else that nobody has shown and that is
how much power can the 24 core use
compared to the 32 core because there's
a chance that it can actually have very
close performance especially under a
heavy load we're also going to talk
about fan noise maximum temperatures and
everything else to help you make the
best decision and find out which one of
these are worth it so let's go ahead and
jump right in we're going to start out
with geekbench 5 which i know is not the
best test but i want to put a twist on
it i'm going to be running pseudo acid
top our terminal script that was created
for us to see
what power and what frequency for the
graphics is used when it's ramping up to
do these 30 tasks all right let's go
ahead and hit run and we are going to
watch and see what happens to the gpu
bam we have 1295 megahertz for the 32
core m1 max and 1289 for the 24 core so
basically the same 1300 megahertz but
what about our 14 inch model this would
also hit 12.95
so the same frequency but wait till i
show you what happens when we actually
put a full consistent load in our next
test all right the scores right now this
is interesting our 32 core 16 inch
scored 67 900 we basically have a
thousand less on our 14 inch 32 core
model and the 24 core 16 inch scored 69
345 so that's roughly i don't know about
8 000 78 000 less than the 32 coin now
what's really interesting is if we break
this score down for the score per core
we get just over 2100 for the 16-inch 32
we get just under that for the 14-inch
32 but the 24 core model gets
2472 points almost 2500 points and then
if we take that and times it by 32
chords this 32 should be at almost 80
000 not 67 900 so that basically means
that apple is limiting this 32 core 16
inch either for maybe battery life
reasons or thermal reasons and if we
look at the peak wattage this proves it
we have 30 watts peak use for these
tests here with the 16 inch model and 32
for the 24 cores there's 24 cores using
more power even though it has less watts
at least for a peak and i don't know how
long that lasts we'll test that in just
a bit and then looking at the 14 inch
model this thing hit almost 37 watts of
power which is crazy and maybe that's
why the battery life on the 14 inch is
so much worse for the 32 core compared
to the other graphics models so could
these results mean that the 24 core
might perform close to the 32 in
extended loads and then other times it
could actually run cooler and quieter
well we're gonna find out in just a sec
but first i want to thank the sponsor of
this video squarespace if you've been
thinking about making your own website
squarespace is seriously the best way to
go you can build a great looking website
like we did with literally no web making
experience it doesn't matter if it's a
portfolio a blog e-commerce or anything
else you simply choose a template and
customize blocks of text and images it's
incredibly simple it's affordable and
ours have been running flawlessly for
years now bringing in tons of traffic
thanks to its built-in seo tools start
your free two-week trial with no credit
card required by going to
squarespace.com
or by using that custom link down below
and when you already launch you will
save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or a domain next i'm gonna run
gfx bench metal this is a gaming test
that is well optimized cross platform
and why i want to run this one is to see
the maximum graphics power
when we are doing a full 100 extended
load all right and it looks like our 24
core went up to 36.8 watts compared to
43.7 for the 32 core 16 inch and the 14
inch is also 43.65
almost identical so all of them use
higher power
uh but the 24 core does use less and
with that this is a really quick test
the fans were off on all the machines
this doesn't account for thermal
throttling but as far as the performance
we have pretty much 310 frames per
second compared to 243 so a lot lower
for the 24 core and
278 for the 14 inch model so even though
the 14 inch also has 32 cores it's a big
loss in performance even though you have
the same amount of wattage because of
probably thermal issues or limitations
now we're gonna go ahead and close this
down in the next test we're gonna test
out thermal throttling and what these
machines can actually run at as well as
the fan noise this is 3d mark's extreme
stress test which will run for 20
minutes and allow us to see what is
going on with these systems
now so far it's been about 20 seconds if
we look at temperatures we're seeing
very similar ones on the 24 core and the
32 core 16 inch models
but the 14 core is definitely getting
hotter quicker as you can see it's
already at 90 degrees compared to low
80s and here's another very interesting
thing the 24 core model is actually
running hotter now
than the other 16 inch model 90 degrees
compared to 77
but the fans are barely on they're
practically just above idle
compared to the 32 core which i can
actually hear the fans right now they're
about halfway and the 14 inch model is
the worst of both it's running hot and
the fans are the loudest out of the
bunch and check this out this is crazy
so as far as wattage right now and full
performance we're about you know five
minutes or so in uh we're getting about
37 watts on the 24 car model compared to
41 on the 32 core so not much of a power
difference just slightly less even
though we have eight less cores but on
the 32 core 14 inch model this thing is
running as low as 23 watts and averaging
around 25 compared to 37 on a model that
has 8 less cores so apple is definitely
limiting this thing a lot and by the way
both of these are using the high powered
mode which wouldn't make a difference
here and we're plugged in on all of them
so it's not like this battery issues
so like i said in my previous video the
32 core 14 inch might actually be slower
than the 24 core 16 inch model we'll
find out in just a bit now as far as
frequencies we're running out
1296 megahertz so basically 1300 on the
32 core also the identical 1300 or just
under that for the 24 core same exact
frequency on the cores so it doesn't
look like we're throttling
but on the 14 inch model we are running
under a thousand megahertz so that's a
big dip in performance we're definitely
seeing thermal throttling on this system
sometimes it's actually going down as
low as the high 800 megahertz which is
crazy so what is going to happen when
we're not only doing graphics tasks like
right now
but for real life testing like blender
3d rendering we're using both your cpu
and your gpu that's going to be crazy
all right we have our results from the
stress test and a 32 core 16 inch has
extremely good stability 99.6
compared to 96.4 on the 24 core which is
weird it has less course means less
thermals why is this thing less stable
well that's because apple tries to keep
this thing running quieter it's clearly
noticeable and the heat is quite a bit
higher because of that so it's less
stable
and because it actually struggled in
certain parts with frame rates but the
14 inch model
91.9 stability and the lowest loop score
was 14952
compared to 15 164
for the six inch model that has eight
less cores and then the 16 inch model 32
got 18
727 and the other interesting thing is
when this 24 core dipped it only did
that like right in the middle
and then the fans kicked up a bit and
then the last run was almost as fast as
the first compared to the 14 inch which
just got slower and slower and slower so
if you're getting a 32 core the 16 inch
model will be 25 more powerful than the
14-inch macbook and if you can't
actually get the larger size you could
deal with it for the same price you can
actually get even better performance a
decent amount better and the other thing
is that the 24 core has 33 percent less
cores than the 32 but the 32 only gets
19 better performance so as far as
performance per core it's actually doing
pretty well but now let's go ahead and
introduce cpu loads as well not just gpu
and it's going to get even more
interesting so for that we are going to
use blender for 3d rendering and i have
the latest alpha version that's going to
use the cpu as well as metal which got a
lot faster and it's going to use most of
the cpu and all of the gpu power so
let's go ahead and select our render
over here and we are going to see how
long it takes and how much faster the 32
cores uh will do this compared to 24.
all right wow this time we're at 96
degrees celsius for the 32 core model
compared to 89 just hit 90. so
definitely cooler now uh with the 24
core and this one my goodness it's
running cooler but i'm guessing it's
throttling a lot on the 14 inch all
right our render is finished
and the 24 core 16 inch took only 12
seconds longer than the 32 core and it
ran cooler and quieter at the same time
we have a minute and 44 seconds for the
32 core 16 and a minute and 56 for the
24 core 16 but what about the 14 inch
over there well you guys saw i actually
didn't run that hot because of
throttling it took two minutes and 10
seconds to do that way slower than the
16 inch one with the same exact graphics
so in this case the 24 core 16 inch is
actually 13
faster than the 32 quart 14 inch model
and of course you get you know way
better battery life as well so that is
very impressive and it's not that far
behind the 32 core so scaling wise
performance per core it is fairly
impressive and now let's take it a step
further with video editing i have some
ak
raw footage right over here we are going
to be
working with it and exporting it which
takes a lot of cpu processing
demosaicing graphics processing a lot of
heat this is going to be the ultimate
test to see
how much of a difference do we get
between 32 cores and 24 and if the 32
core is a rip off for the extreme users
out there that really push their machine
so let's go ahead and export this all
right guys this is crazy how's the 24
core faster than the 32 core at
exporting and it's gaining speed as it's
going well let's take a look at ask the
top and all right here you go this is
why the 24k is running at almost full
performance about 1260 megahertz 1240
whereas a 32 core it's running at just
above a thousand megahertz it's
throttling a lot more and then our
14-inch 32 core this thing's that's the
high 700s or the low 800s so this thing
is throttling a ton
so we're seeing that the 24 core
even though it's 33 less course it is
throttling less causing it to be faster
than the more expensive 32 core model
and bm we have a results
wow okay so the 14 inch it took
10 minutes
and one second the 32 core more
expensive 16 inch
took 7 minutes and 35 seconds that's a
pretty impressive improvement over the
14-inch about 25
faster than that machine but the 24
quart cheaper one
it did it in seven minutes and 13
seconds faster than the 32 core
by about 22 seconds or so
so this just proves to us that if you
need the most performance and you're
pushing the cpu and you're pushing the
gpu
it doesn't mean that you need to buy the
most expensive machine
24 core 16 inch
it's gonna have better battery life
overall
if you push it very lightly it'll just
be a little bit slow or bang for the
buck the performance per cores is really
good it's going to run a little bit
louder in some situations but under
heavy load quieter which we just saw
here
perform better
and cost you less money
this is the unicorn model that and
before when i talked about it was way
longer wait times to get and they kept
delaying my model so i literally had to
get it from somebody else to test it
and not only does it perform great with
the 16-inch model
if you're getting the 14 inch model
you literally even for easy tasks the
difference is very minimal i made a
whole video on that guys you guys could
check it out right over there but
overall i am just so impressed with the
24 core model not only in the 14 inch
also in the 16 inch model so thank you
guys for watching click that circle
above to help us gain a million
subscribers that is our goal we would
absolutely appreciate it this one max
and i'll see you in the next video
[Music]
you